this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know that the cash app is the
number one happened finance but did you
realize that you can get the most
powerful debit card in the world with
the cash shops cash card just select a
boost in your cash app swipe the cash
card and save 10% or more at Whole Foods
Shake Shack Chipotle Taco Bell a
chick-fil-a and all coffee shops around
the country we'll talk about this more
later on the show download the cash app
for free on the App Store or Google Play
market now what's up guys how you doing
it's episode 101 of congratulations we
broke 100 and that's amazing and you
guys have helped this happen I'd love to
say couldn't have done it without you
but the truth is could have done it
without you but it would have been a
really [ __ ] long depressing 100 our
suicide note because it would have just
been me talking to absolutely nobody so
it really does help that you guys have
listened because I do talk to myself by
myself in my house but you guys are now
my audience and that's great now it is
still the new studio it's a little bit
echoey and it will be the last time that
it is actually because we are getting it
sound proofed tomorrow or the next day
so it's on my babies and that's how it's
going it's free [ __ ] you can make your
room however you want it and we're gonna
make this one soundproof well I'm I like
this dude you guys Happy New Year Happy
New Year right it's 2019 and you know I
love when the clock strokes midnight on
new year on the new year because
everyone stops saying see you next year
and that's annoying as [ __ ] when people
do that because that's as interesting as
the good Halloween cost
at the party and in real life sad for
doing it anyway we're live on my app
here you could hear the podcast first
see the podcast first I'm right now I'm
back to being solo I'm rolling on my
dull up my babies because my brother was
four episode 100 and we got a lot of
love for it man my brother hit me up
yesterday and he was like how come
nobody's talking [ __ ] and I was like
look it's because you know the fan base
is built in the babies are strong we're
a cult dude and we don't talk [ __ ] and I
was like he thought he was like yeah but
usually there's some [ __ ] [ __ ] talk I
was like you're enough like me that
they're just in we have got a good
banter we've got a good we've got a good
banter and we were having it we were
having a good time but we're back today
regular programming just me so if you
like my brother sorry but you can go
[ __ ] look at his podcast when it
comes out when it when it does but
anyway uh it's 2019 I'm on Tiger belly
this week - I had fun with with Bobby
and kalila and the other [ __ ] 14
people that they have in that apartment
in that in that friggin room when we do
did I swear to god I do Tiger belly
there's seven people in the room it's
the littlest room in his goddamn
apartment hey Bobby you're gonna have
that many people in your podcast put it
in the [ __ ] living room at least dude
it's in like the back [ __ ] I guess
it's is it even it's not even a bedroom
doesn't have a [ __ ] but a bathroom in
it it's like a [ __ ] little room that
would be in an office with a closet and
I swear to god one guy sits in the
goddamn closet I swear to God and it's
always a different guy and it's sad as
[ __ ] it's like like it's like every time
I go back as a new guy that sits in the
closet and he's just like oh yeah no I
[ __ ] and it was the old guy and and
they get it oh he got tired of sitting
in the goddamn closet that's why that's
why why the [ __ ] would you you know how
dehumanizing it is to sit in a closet
name one guy that sit in a closet for
more than eight hours that didn't that
thought more of himself after he
laughter he [ __ ] got out name one guy
that's been in a closet for an hour that
thought more of himself when they got
out anyway I'm on episode 175 of tiger
belly
and Bobby Lee is a goddamn cartoon so um
anyway 100 episodes [ __ ] so awesome I
love it and uh and I want to talk about
you know I don't give a [ __ ] we're just
I'm when I got my you know what you know
what happened today I I went early to
the coffee bean I got a new by the way
got a new [ __ ] coffee bean that I go
to sometimes so sorry if you were
looking for me at the old one today but
I wasn't there but it's January 2nd now
that this is coming out and let me say
something all right when you're I guess
starting the 23rd of December all bets
are off you can kind of wear whatever
the [ __ ] you want to wear girls aren't
wearing makeup they're like this is the
real me whatever I've got kids I'm
shopping all good dudes are showing up
in [ __ ] onesies and like at like a
cafe and you're like alright it's the
[ __ ] holiday time you know [ __ ] it
and what they call the taint of the
holiday season between Christmas and New
Year's Eve because nobody does [ __ ] and
it's like in between the balls and the
anus because the Christmas is Christmas
has balls and New Year's is the [ __ ]
anus or Christmas is your [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then New Year's is the anus anyway
it's a family show but it's a taint the
holidays and all bets are off people
show up they're like it's like they're
in it's like they're in [ __ ] and they're
on they're storming the beaches at
Normandy at [ __ ] Target and they're
just like oh no you know what it's more
like the not even what's the walking
dead [ __ ] more like Night of the
Living Dead where it's just like they're
walking slow and it's just like horrible
it looks horrible and and the makeup and
the special effects are horrible but
that's how everyone kind of is on the
taint of the [ __ ] holiday season and
then and then so it's January 2nd so
January 2nd now and I went to go to the
coffee bean to get my thoughts together
for the podcast didn't really do it
always say I'm going to do it but
instead I just peruse Instagram and
Twitter and see what people are saying
about me it's a sad so actually what
happens do I come up with ideas yes
do I do it in the time I have a lot of
myself to do it no do I do it all week
yes do I sometimes write them down yes
do I write them all don't know do I say
I'll do it later
yes am i lazy yes does it work sometimes
am i disrespectful to you guys yes I'm
just a problem to myself you guess what
the pockets be better if I did it yes
am I gonna change no I am Who I am
babies and that's what this podcast is
about it's about being who you are okay
it's about being who you are it's not
about changing is it about growing a
little bit but it's mostly about
remaining who you are and people barely
change no matter what yes do people
think I'm really gonna make a difference
I'm gonna make a changes or just do they
know it's all good kind of but anyway do
it I was at the coffee bean and limit I
see something dude this chick came out
it came to the coffee bean now she had
her onesie on now immediately what I
thought of is it's January 2nd this what
I thought of get past the [ __ ] anus
you're past the anus therefore put pants
on therefore put a top on therefore put
on more articles of clothing than one
it's January 2nd get it together
hey chick change January 2nd I swear to
god you were a goddamn three-piece suit
or a [ __ ] denim shirt and denim pant
pants some sort of Canadian tuxedo you
put on even if you want to put on cargo
pants and be a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and we're like an oakley t-shirt you do
that but you don't act like it's the
taint when you're past the paynus you
understand that's it she walked
was [ __ ] December 28th I didn't like
it and then she sat there with a bunch
of other people and had a meeting at the
cafe in a onesie and the other people
were dressed past the tick they were
past the anus past the anus starring
Michael Douglas they killed my wife
past the anus every movie Michael
Douglas is in he's like they killed my
wife I can't help it they killed my wife
past the anus starring Michael Douglas
and Academy Award nominee Toni Collette
did when they say actually she won
didn't she
Academy by the way if I'm ever at
nominated for an Academy Award okay yeah
I don't ever want that and I don't win I
don't ever want them to promote me like
I I was a nominee that's like so like
and loser Toni Collette past the anus
they killed my wife and Michael Douglas
they killed my wife never won an Academy
Award Michael Douglas passed the anus
its January 2nd [ __ ] um so anyway yeah
it's the [ __ ] past the taint of the
holiday so I'll put on a goddamn outfit
no I'm talking about put on goddamn
mouth put on goddamn mouth
did she win for 6 cents let's talk about
how good actually six cents was and then
let's talk about actually [ __ ] that
we're not going to talk about that you
know we're gonna talk about we're gonna
talk about how good unbreakable was and
we're gonna talk about how annoying it
is that people say it isn't good and a
lot of people say it is good I'm not
trying to be like one of those guys
that's like oh yeah you know I heard
like somebody tweeted today my friend
you know that got backhanded compliment
I'm not trying to the back in a comment
what I'm saying is unbreakable a lot
people say it was good but some [ __ ]
because they think they're interesting
or because they don't really know what
life has got what's going on and how
life is they pretend they say stuff like
oh yeah they lie they love to be like
and let's normal on fell off after that
after sixth sense yeah no no he didn't
by the way unbreakable is so [ __ ]
good it's so good
all right it's such a good movie and
then split came out and it's amazing and
let me tell you something I can't
[ __ ] wait to watch glass I can't wait
to watch glass
Sam Jackson and Bruce will listen to
movie together in they weren't when were
they when they weren't they weren't
weren't in they weren't they in die hard
for dude why can't I talk you ever see
that kid give me em there I'm the knee
and what was the kit you know I'm
talking about they what's he say what is
that thing called I want to play it we
all never know one fire we'll never know
and oh yeah if you had a dream right kid
what dream kid okay dream kid YouTube
cool how the thing is making the thing
here we got this kit this is how it was
for a second it's not in it's not
working one fire got one [ __ ] goddamn
job what do you mean I'm playing it let
me tell you some after watching that I
realized one thing and I don't mean this
in any funny way or a hypothetical way
or anything like that after I saw that
you have to understand that's my child
that's my child
that's how cute it is when that happens
I go like this that's my kid I don't
give a [ __ ] whose kid that really is
it's mine now because he's so goddamn
cute you ever see a kid that's so cute
and you think hey that's my kid not even
in a cute not even in a creepy way
you're just like
you know what that kid belongs to me now
I get it
you can go home with the [ __ ] person
that you know you came out of but just
know deep down kid you're my kid now
because that's the cutest thing I ever
heard in my life
also how proud he is at the end of what
he says is hilarious he sits back in
smiles hey kid you [ __ ] this up
royally okay you [ __ ] it up royally
yeah ever no no I mean I don't even yes
I have I have had a dream where you were
you want him to do you so much that you
can do anything actually kid I have had
a dream so much that you want him to do
you so much that you that you can do
anything I mean even if you think the
mumbles out it makes no sense you ever
have a dream where you yeah why do kids
do that [ __ ] so would they just get
out of a pool what are they in a [ __ ]
cryo chamber ah hey kid he in a cryo
chamber anyway dude yes the answer to
that is yes and you're my child so
anyway what was I was I talking about
even uh oh I'm breakable but before that
I don't know it doesn't matter
but sixth sense yes alright anyway
anyway my special came out or my my
thing my episode of comedians of the
world and it the response has been
awesome I'm really happy about it
really happy about it and it's very cool
Netflix put out a comedians of the world
thing I even tried to I even tried to
watch some of the comedians of the world
in German just to see what it would be
like and it's [ __ ] interesting dude
you will have to watch it in subtitles
which means you know it's not really as
good because you got a the delivery and
[ __ ] is all is important but it's
interesting to watch and it's cool too
it's it's cool too
I don't know it's cool to see all that
[ __ ] but anyway net Netflix put up 47
comedians around the world doing
stand-up and I am one of them the
episodes and if you haven't seen it turn
it on yet a lot of people are saying
like I can't find it it's because it's
under comedians of the world and I put
it on all over my social media so just
also try a little harder you know people
want [ __ ] spoon-fed they're like can't
find it they'll type in CH not here it's
not here Chris Rock came up ok watch
that then I don't give a [ __ ] you know I
don't want to have to babysit you but
watch it and then and then but the
responsibly good I shot it uh about
maybe seven months ago six months ago
and I never know what I you know after I
shoot it I forget about it like I
haven't done that routine since then
around then maybe I did it a little bit
after that like for a week but then I
get bored of it because I know it's
coming out so I don't want to do it
anymore so I talk about Australia and my
trip to Australia which I actually
talked about on the podcast a little bit
but I turned it into material and then
put it on stage and it was in an
intimate venue there like two 200 people
there was really cool and and I'm glad
the way it turned out I didn't watch it
again but I just saw a little bit of it
because I was like how did this even
turn out you know and I'm happy with it
but people people seem to really like it
I never know what the [ __ ] people are
gonna say the Internet's a weird man
people say everything I mean somebody is
somebody I was just looking today I got
a I can't I got a stop looking I don't
you know yeah right you know you're
talking and you never know and someone
to do you so much that you never saw
you can do anything so I basically I saw
this person tweet was super bummed that
I saw you do this set a year ago at
House of Blues I it by I don't
understand how some people do say stuff
like that and I don't get I don't
understand what they think stand-up is
like you have to you don't just go
onstage and wing it
do they think that and I I think they
know that right they have to know that
you don't just go onstage and wing it so
because I know buddy can be that stupid
nobody can actually think that so do
they think you work on it for two weeks
or for a month or three months or what
because that's not what happens first of
all and I'm not even trying to brag I
put out material quicker than anybody I
mean there are people who put up
material as quickly as I do but nobody
really does it is quicker than a year my
last presser came out less than a year
ago right yeah it came out like 10 18
right or was it over II I can I never
know that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I don't came
up 2018 it came out in June was it 2017
it's just
Okemah okay so came out a year and a
half ago really yes that's what
okay so what is it now 2018 so okay so a
year and a half ago and on top of that
will this will add to it I'm doing a
complete new set from the thing that you
can see on Netflix so that's one hour
two hours two and a half hours there's
crazy hard to count my fingers for two
and a half but two and a half hours of
material in less than two years okay I
mean people are doing it that quickly
nobody doing it quicker than that so
what do people think I want to know what
I want to know what those people and
it's not the majority it's the minority
that don't understand how it stand-up
works but what how how much what do you
think I want to know what I want to know
somebody out there who's listening to
this or if you have a friend or
something I want to know what they think
it's like cuz i retweeted that person I
was like yo you're [ __ ] an idiot like
I worked on this and cuz I only worked
on I worked on this not only but I
worked on the set the Netflix set that
just came out in January second I worked
on it for eight months
I worked on it December January February
March April May June July is when I shot
it so that's eight months that's you
know long enough but but that's you know
that's long enough
and then I dumped it after that so I
want to know and I don't even mean this
in a defensive way I don't mean this in
a [ __ ] because I think that most
people think that that's that that kind
of a person that says that is just an
idiot because they don't know how to
stand up Forks but I want to know if you
are that person what it actually what
you think stand-up comedy is because
there's literally no stand-up comedian
unless it's a crowd work set that you're
going to do that just comes up on stage
and make [ __ ] up for their stand-up
routine unless it's you know no I don't
I mean I literally don't think it's ever
happened in the history of stand-up so
anyway and if it did it will be horrible
oh it would be horrible
anyway oh if you are that person let me
know it but thanks for watching for this
special really because I think that it
you know it's very cool that you'd you'd
continue to support me and I do work
really [ __ ] hard and it's always nice
to hear that people are enjoying what
I'm doing when they do and so thank you
for that and you know some people say
some really [ __ ] humbling [ __ ] like
and it really like I know I give off
this air of like I don't give a [ __ ] but
I do I really do give a [ __ ] about what
you know about about my work and and so
if people are you know I mean some
people say nice [ __ ] like all you know I
got battling depression I this and that
the other thing and it's [ __ ] cool to
make up a laugh like that and that's it
that's all I have to say about that it
was weird how the this was peeking in
Netflix the other thing that was Netflix
took down an episode of the the Patriot
Act which is crazy to me I understand
why they did it you know I think they
thought there were legal ramifications
and the lawyer that they were talking to
their lawyers and said they took it down
because the government in Saudi Arabia
said that they didn't want it in their
country because they were making fun of
the crown prince or whatever but man I
just think that that's what I don't
understand is in Saudi Arabia so the
Saudi Arabian government is I can't make
fun of the [ __ ] prince so we're gonna
ban this episode what they don't realize
is that's oh that I guess they don't
realize it it's just gonna make people
watch it more yeah they only banned it
there yeah in Saudi Arabia but like but
it's gonna make people want to watch it
more it's certainly gonna make people
outside of Saudi Arabia look it up and
then in Saudi Arabia you can still see
it on YouTube YouTube was like nah [ __ ]
you guys we'll live it up so what the
[ __ ] its if I say hey don't if I said
right now dude don't listen episode 40
in my podcast the next thing you're
doing is going to look at 40 of my [ __ ]
Podcast after you might even not finish
this one
III don't how could you be that stupid
and be the [ __ ] government ah lots of
stupid governments out there put that on
my [ __ ] tombstone lots of stupid
government's out there so yeah I don't
know dude but anyway shout at this Hasan
Minhaj who's great at what he does and
and the Patriot Act I tweeted the link
or no I didn't tweet it but I was trying
to find the oh no I did tweet it I
tweeted the link on the YouTube for that
that episode and I was like if you're in
Saudi Arabia Arabia specifically enjoy
this I mean dude it's just so stupid I
love how people get so outraged about
the censorship to the censorship thing -
like it's not really that bad if you
think about it like I mean in Saudi
Arabia it is but an American people are
like nervous about it being in America
like yo people can say whatever the [ __ ]
they want and then people can be
outraged at whatever the [ __ ] they want
that's it that's it that's how it is
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] say what I'm gonna
say you're gonna get mad okay
cool that's America and then I'm gonna
say more [ __ ] I mean unless you're
[ __ ] that guy who got banned from
YouTube Alex Jones right but that's just
YouTube they're banning it that's not
America saying he can't do it he can do
it God that guy that guy looks like he
[ __ ] spills mayonnaise from a sandwich
on his [ __ ] face all the time Alex
Jones that guy couldn't look more like
he has [ __ ] mayonnaise and mustard on
his shirt more than that more than
anyone else in the world like your uncle
we're like yeah you got some on your
face and he just wipes it to the other
side that's what Alex Jones looks like I
don't know you know it's weird to think
about - and I was think about this year
that there is like how crazy the time
has been in America and then how always
I was talking to my dad he was like dude
the 60s and 70s early the 50s and 60s
and 70s he's like we thought the world
was gonna end then - he was like we
didn't have the internet so we didn't
know it every second of the day I was
like yeah I mean it always seems like
the world's gonna [ __ ] end you know it
was always seemed like member this song
we didn't start the fire everyone
thought the [ __ ] world was gonna end
during that like during that time too
and that was the 80s that was when [ __ ]
was [ __ ] I mean you don't even hear
much about how the world was about to
end in the 80s but everyone thought it
was gonna end then - did everyone always
thinks the world's gonna end
I think we're gonna be fine here's the
thing eventually we're not gonna be fine
but that's gonna because some [ __ ]
global [ __ ] NACA system you know what do
you call it like like some [ __ ]
climate [ __ ] we're gonna have to move to
Mars or some you know it's not gonna be
because of war will always figure it out
or people will be dying but America I
feel like generally if you live in a big
city because you always hear all these
big city people that are just like oh
what's the happening to the world you'd
do the same [ __ ] every day you know I'm
talking about how is your life changed
if you just live kind of in Chicago and
you're just chillin
you go to work you [ __ ] go to sleep
you party
you come a little bit and you have a
sandwich unless you lost your job
because of what you know what the [ __ ]
going on I understand that but like you
hear all these people complaining in
Hollywood and it's like it what I don't
know I not [ __ ] know like somebody
[ __ ] somebody else just be like yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy what's happening in
the world the world's changing and then
they just ski that down the mountain on
vacation and you're like what
by the way how I would say how bad like
I was trying to think about skiing I
can't remember was talking about this
with but they were like have you ever
skied not as I [ __ ] yet one other kid
until I realized what the [ __ ] am i
doing standing on blades on ice because
if you told skiing is the is the richest
whitest [ __ ]
like if you can like um it's so white
to have a great life and then to do
dangerous things for the [ __ ] of it
that's why I always say escape rooms are
the whitest things it's like oh [ __ ]
pretend we're trapped when people are
really trapped you know but like skiing
dude is so white it's unbelievable
first of all you have a [ __ ] lift
take you to the top of the mountain you
[ __ ]
okay climb up [ __ ] get a [ __ ] ice
axe climb up you [ __ ] [ __ ] alright
so you get a chair you get a chair in
the [ __ ] sky to take you to the top
of the mountain you good-for-nothing
[ __ ] alright then you get to the top
you've got [ __ ] thousand-dollar
blades on your feet [ __ ] and then you
fly down a mountain it takes four
seconds and the rest of the time you've
got to take that lift up ski there's not
enough [ __ ] action in skiing you go
down the mountain it takes four seconds
and then you're on the lift for [ __ ]
12 and a half hours it's like the flight
to Australia [ __ ] Hey Dude take those
God anytime you got a hold poles to get
somewhere stop you lazy [ __ ] get a nice
axe
about how [ __ ] do people look when you
get off the lift by the way you can't do
it cool just standing up and getting off
the lift you couldn't look more [ __ ]
than that you know why because you're
going the same for like a few seconds
you're going the same speed that's why
you're on the lift at a certain speed
and then you get off the same speed
we're watching a video right now where a
guy got stuck on the lift and the guy
jumped out to into like a safety bag
it's just dude if skiing didn't exist
okay and somebody was we were at the top
of the mountain no we were at the bottom
of a mountain and somebody was like hey
let's go to the top and [ __ ] slide
down and put these blades on each foot
I'd just be like hey man what that's
dangerous as [ __ ] why would we do that
and then the guy looks at me and says
fun I go like this you're out to lunch
bro you're you know what you are too
wide you know what you are too wide you
know what you are you're not white
you're white when people [ __ ] do that
when old guys think they're being
correct by going white those kinds of
guys same kinds of guys who say Jesus
instead of Jesus white gross hey if you
say white you have bad breath did you
know that you do so and then and then
they got and then they got a [ __ ]
lift to take you up dude it's not a
sport if you got to take a lift period
that'd be like if somebody hit a [ __ ]
homerun and then they got on a lift and
went all around the bases run [ __ ] run
two people falling down on skis and then
snowboarding dude I went skiing until I
got in until I went on a jump and then I
did of what they
I did the full scorpion which the back
of my [ __ ] heels almost touched the
back of my head because my chest had a
[ __ ] jump and I literally thought up
this is it gonna be gonna be dead now
this reveal I I was like up guess I got
to give my POG collection to someone it
was then it was around then okay cool
hey guys you already know the cache app
is the number one app in finance but did
you realize that you can get the most
powerful debit card in the world with
the cash apps cash card yeah you did
realize that because you're a subscriber
to my podcast the cash card comes with
boosts a feature you can get anywhere
else you can't get anywhere else because
cash app invented it so not only are
they the best cash app they are
inventors okay just select a boost in
your cash app swipe the cash card and
save ten percent or more at Whole Foods
Shake Shack Chipotle Taco Bell
chick-fil-a and all coffee shops around
the country the coffee shop boost takes
$1 off at any coffee shop including
Dunkin and Starbucks drink a hundred
cups a year save $100 it's that simple
you don't need to be a mathematician to
know about that 100 drink hundred cups
save hundred dollars become a part of
the greatest rewards program ever and
download the cash app now it's a number
one app for a reason and the cash card
is the only debit card with boosts and
of course when you download the cash app
and enter the referral code congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 to the times up Legal Defense
Fund visit the App Store or Google Play
market and download the cash app dude by
the way are you with me when I say
January 1st for real feels like 17
minutes I swear to god it feels like
it's the quickest day ever that day if
scientists were came home they were like
actually the way the world world turns
and the way the light is technically the
the light the
the day is only even though it seems
even though we go through all the hours
and the Sun does cover all of the space
the day is only thirteen hours I'd say
wow that's crazy but I believe it maybe
it's not about the day being 24 hours
all the timing may be January 1st is 12
hours maybe it's not about time it's
about the way we perceive it welcome to
TED talks so anyway it's [ __ ] it's it
is pretty it is pretty bonkers how short
that day is sound board needs to stay
open
minion Yammer not in the amber no can't
play it one fire I don't know why this
doesn't work but it doesn't work it's
all good
hey so kanye is for trump again now he's
for trump he was like I got out of the
sunken place and then he's like never
mind psyche I'm back and where he's
gonna wear the red head of concerts I
think that guy just is either really
crazy or just does it for the reaction
and because he's that's the one I gotta
say that's the one thing I like about
[ __ ] Drake is that his [ __ ] is about
I like more than one thing about Drake I
by the way I liked her I'm a Drake fan
straight up but he is like one of the
only rappers that's that big and it's
because of the music you know I'm
talking about
like it's because of his music it's not
because of shoes it's not because of
fashion it's not because a what he's
saying in the [ __ ] on Twitter it's
not because of
you know who we married or his family
Drake's just [ __ ] putting out good
music but these guys like Kanye and even
me go so I mean which peoples they love
the music it's just liked it but there
it's about him by you know the mingoes
bought this chain he goes did that or
[ __ ] quavo is breaking up with the
girl or by the way he's a guava that's
going out with cardi B one of them I
think it's quavo dude when he went to
the [ __ ] he's just a creep creepy guy
actually like he went to she she went to
was it that rolling loud was she was
headlining it that in she was like the
first female performer ever ever - oh no
it's offset that that dates are it
doesn't matter you know at all oh is it
quoi here's something that's never
important hey is it quavo or offset
either you know who's dating cardi B
either of its oats quavo hey you know
what no it's not
it's quavo I don't give a [ __ ]
quavo you know quavo is [ __ ] you enough
then enough it's quavo yeah where we
Fran's at the French version of it
were we in [ __ ] France am I on a
veranda anyway offset hey dud man she's
dating cardi B were married to her and
he can't stop cheating or whatever which
is hilarious it's not hilarious but so
she she was like the headliner and then
he came with a sign and like interrupted
and was like I'm sorry like dude you're
not like this isn't a [ __ ] John
Hughes movie like
just if the three members are directly
related and were raised together quavo
is take-offs uncle an offset is Cuevas
cousin I mean head dude okay so hold on
let me read that again imagine trying to
make sense of it okay huevo is takeoffs
uncle
okay so cleveo if qwave always takeoffs
then that means takeoff dad it's maybe
takeoffs dad's brother okay and offset
its Cuevas cousin okay okay you know
what honestly to all that okay because i
literally learned something on january
2nd that was the least important thing I
learned all year I didn't know they were
related though that's pretty cool I
guess also how is he is uncle when
they're the same age you know black guys
will be like my uncle's younger than me
white guys too though you know white
guys like like like like you southern
white guys they'll be like hey I'm 35
yeah meet my uncle and uncle be like hey
I do poopy and you're like oh that's not
your kid not he'll now my dad he's my
dad's brother he'll now he's my dad's
brother he's four I do poopy yeah but my
dad what happened was what happened was
my dad got remarried
married nutted in a girl and then had
that baby uncle so it's my uncle he kind
of keeps me in check tells me what to do
and then I wipe his ass when he shits
his diaper
oh god you sorry I got to take my uncle
into the other room
they made a stinker
anyway hi my grandpa my grandpa hey this
is my grandpa he's 9 what the [ __ ] how
does that even make sense
heya cuz I'm from the real Seth and I'm
a lot of [ __ ] Asians don't do that at
all
Asians have straight-up lineage it
lineage that just [ __ ] works the [ __ ]
out and let me tell you something too if
you're Asian and your great-grandfather
isn't alive you're not Asian because
Asians have those [ __ ] alive
and they live with you two Japanese
[ __ ] 35% of Japanese people
their great-great grandpa is alive and
they're a hundred and one and it goes
like this their great great Grandpa's
101 their great grandpa is 84 their
grandpa is 60 their dad is 40 and then
they're 20 and that's just how it is man
and then they also have a kid that's
[ __ ] floor and that kid has a
great-great-great grandpa so that's
Asian is [ __ ]
and they don't and they and they only
they never take advice from whoever is
younger than them they always just take
advice from whoever's the oldest I want
to have a TED talk where I do that and
it's not jokes and I talk seriously
about it and people believe it but
that's some Asian [ __ ]
Asians would be like you have uncle that
is a younger than a year me my uncle boy
it's my uncle hi Ida poopy how is it the
possible for your own my dad noted in
his new wife my dad nerded in his new
wife and that's my whatever make him
your brother my dad nerd wait would it
yeah my dad oh yeah that's right I'm
getting all the [ __ ] who cares we're
just talking about offsetting quavo but
but offset I mean but offset [ __ ] it
all up man so he cheated and then he
[ __ ] keeps [ __ ] it up more but
they got a kid though you gotta try and
work it out for the kid you know
imagine your dad's name was offset
though probably got probs all right so
what should we do some what do you call
it what do they call them craigslist ads
misconnections turn sumit intemperance
craigslist and looking for Tina Valle
what this guy's subject looking for Tina
hit me up if you got any what's Tina we
gotta look that up in the urban
dictionary or some [ __ ] Tina Tina slang
Tina oh it's a drug Oh
meth T the drug of choice is typically
methamphetamine known as Tina or T but
other drugs are also used Tina
tweet right it says that here okay
anyway he's looking for Tina so if it
got Tina hit him up some chick named
Tina hey a cupcake needed quickly I mean
Oh cupcake ill quickly I'll do it I need
a I need a bunch of guys to come on a
girl's face hurry up my girl wants to
get cooked today is her birthday and we
don't have much time hey guy first of
all relax you can do it tomorrow she
wants me to have fun with another girl
and ooh and come inside her for her
birthday oh now I get why he doesn't
have much how cuz she probably like it
has to happen today and he's like really
I can do it she is shy and not sure if
she wants to join or just hear about it
I'm twenty hyung five seven see short
dark hair and tan okay
need a girl ASAP any type will do
desperate hey I'll take whatever men I
mean what
hey he got problems in your relationship
dude my girl wants to get cooked she
wants me to comment I mean like talked
her into it at another one
where are they on fire oh my god dude
the title of this one used to rub you
Valencia used to take care of all your
aches and pains like to do it again me
white male 56 year old 510 200 pounds do
not contact me with on solicitors I used
to rub you dude how do you lose a guy's
number you used to rub you know hey man
hey my phone crashed got to go on
misconnections down low brother West
Adams I would love to meet the gardener
that cut the grass next door maybe after
work you can come over to my house and
drink a beer with me I'm the black guy
that live alone and always outside
watching you and I'm always down to meet
someone new talk to you later
I mean you're talking about [ __ ] you
know just say it this is Craigslist
misconnection he's like yeah let's just
have a beer hey you don't need to be
cagey it's okay oh this guy writes it's
okay to contact this post poster with
services or commercial interests this
guy's looking for a job too hey you want
to [ __ ] or you want me to mow your lawn
hey you want to [ __ ] do you need some
[ __ ] or do you need some a shelf
built Oh we'll go to that one come on
dude you don't one fire almost get by
this one and it's a really good Latin
bottom mail for mail Hey calling
yourself a chub is kind of like just
cashing out you know hey you know what
the guy's got
just like I was talking my friend once
Ryan and he was like you know and I
sometimes flirt with he's real thin now
but he was like I think he was like I
sometimes thought with just like being a
fat guy [ __ ] it I'm just saying give up
just eating whatever and just forget
work because if that's got to be a load
off your mind if you're just a guy and
you're like fluctuating and you're like
you know I work out and I think about
what I eat but it will be way less
stressful to just be a fat guy and say
[ __ ] it and not worry about it not work
I don't have to work out this way my day
is open for that from you know from I
got two more hours where I don't have to
do [ __ ] and I don't have to stress about
what I mean I'm just gonna be a fat guy
and [ __ ] it that's the guy that'll be
like then to be like to succumb and say
hey you know what I'm a I'm a Latin chub
[ __ ] it
so he writes hey guys Latin chub bottom
here 26 6-4 height looking for some fun
tonight I'll be free after work after 9
p.m.
please be able to host Wow humans are
amazing you know they always have like a
documentary that's like on some [ __ ]
that like humans are amazing in they
they can jump forever and they can they
can swim and they can [ __ ] do
anything how about the fact that you can
just be a bottom go over some guy's
house get blasted in and call yourself a
chub where's that episode Netflix or is
that [ __ ] episode eat chub where's
your Netflix episode hey chub
why aren't yep Assad foreign humans are
amazing
[ __ ] this National Geographic needs to
do an episode on this Latin chub amazing
here's another one last one and then
we'll call it a day huh flame and saddle
West Hollywood course is there anything
more flamin s'more West Hollywood than
flaming saddle you were the guy in the
beanie I was the guy in the tie first of
all these guys they got to figure out
what the dress code was cuz they are
complete opposites they obviously
weren't at a function we kept eyeing
each other but something held me back
did it hold you back too so not sexy the
way he wrote it so wanted to be [ __ ]
poetic and sexy so was the opposite of
that you were the guy in the beanie I
was the guy in the tie which kept eyeing
each other but something held me back
did it hold you back to do not contact
me with unsolicited services for offers
hey if you're the guy in the tie oh yeah
if you're the guy in the beanie dude hit
this guy up
flaming saddle West Hollywood
unbelievable okay anyway I got Twitter
questions Boccieri at we get it in nice
I got a two-part question for you we get
it we get it in that's because of what I
said in the podcast right we're getting
we're getting it in but the [ __ ] I
hope so otherwise change yet
I got a two-part question for you one if
you're on death row what would your last
meal be I mean dude
probably just some that's a good
question
fun dip and I just [ __ ] spray it all
over so they'd have to clean that [ __ ]
up just all four
when sorts a colorful powder so that
guards would have to clean it up alright
hold it in my hands and then it [ __ ]
throw it in their eyes spices so I could
do that [ __ ] like I did the [ __ ]
Morgan die sake when I was a kid I took
the salt and I said you want to see my
ninja dust and he said yeah I said no
and I said what do you want to see it he
says well what is it
I said well you can't you can't I can't
tell you I have to show you and he says
what the [ __ ] is it and I was like do
you want to see my ninja dust and I said
well okay fine then and I threw the salt
in his eyes and he goes oh what you
doing whatever get didn't what are we
doing do it so shitty that I did that
but I was 13 and I'm sorry Morgan
it was that lock a Bonita at a Mexican
restaurant and I threw [ __ ] salt and
my best friend who is Japanese guy's
face for sure had a great guy cramp all
living and at the ruin his eyes and he
said what would [ __ ] you doing whatever
you doing any other time he said what
the [ __ ] you doing what the [ __ ] you
doing is when I scored it on my I scored
a point on our own goal because we were
in soccer together and he [ __ ] was
the goalie and I was defense and I tried
to do a bicycle kick and it went in his
skull and he said whatever you do
whatever you doing there's the only two
times I've heard all the were you doing
from working there's a key it's all this
is called on your own goal sorry I'm
sorry mostly about the salt thing but
whatever who cares about AYSO soccer
two-parter what would be your preferred
method of execution and then he writes
some morbid I don't know [ __ ]
jumping can't do that but I would I
would ask to jump off the top because at
least then you'd feel [ __ ] at least
it's a different experience you'd be
like whoa
firing squad that's what you'd pick why
one fire says firing squad one firing
squad dude what a [ __ ] I wouldn't want
that why wouldn't you want lethal
injection over that no lethal injection
firing squad would be ill that is a good
point you would it would be ill I
wouldn't want guillotine though because
then you'd see your head coming off you
you're alive for like two seconds after
that you'd see your head you'd see the
basket coming up to your face and you'd
still go let you go like this because
you couldn't you pick your head you try
to blegh go to move I mean what the [ __ ]
must that feel like you try to go to
move your hands to cover your face but
you wouldn't have your hands anymore and
you just the last thing you'd [ __ ]
your face would hit that [ __ ] basket
that you could just buy it like Crate &
Barrel or some [ __ ] you know some
[ __ ] carrying basket Jesus I don't
know firing squad is kind of ill though
but what if they like missed a little
bit and then you're just like bleeding I
know I don't Happy New Year guys you
know all right
I'm out of here dude we had one sponsor
today so the show was still the same
length I was gonna make it shorter but
it wasn't because I enjoy talking to you
guys
download the cash up for free on the App
Store or Google Play market and two
rewards code Congrats get five dollars
give five dollars - times up thank you
so much guys download the Chris D'Elia
app to watch the first 5 verse 10
minutes of each episode live and the new
merch is being a restock very soon
follow the store on Twitter at Chris
D'Elia store we're constantly restocking
it got crazy limited because the
Christmas because the holidays I
understand but subscribe rate and review
the show tweet me by using the handle
congrats pod please rate and review the
show it really helps and it's on youtube
subscribe to the youtube channel watch
it on youtube and watch my new special
on under comedians of the world on
Netflix
and have a good have a good 2019 arrrooo
every everyone who's listening take take
take care guys
[Music]